>>Reto: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and welcome to This
Week in Android Development for October 1st,
2012.
Last week on Android Developers Live, we broadcast
from our brand new studio balanced a hair's
breadth from the gaping maw of a formless
void that threatens to expand and engulf us
all in its speechless depths.
Each week we'll be throwing a team member
into the depths of the void in an effort to
appease our shapeless dread overlords.
In Android Design in Action last Tuesday Roman
and Nick took Glimmer and Camera Zoom FX out
behind the woodshed for a full UX makeover.
Check out the video to see how they fared.
On Thursday we invited the camera App Clinic
patients to be interviewed on Android Developers
Strike Back.
Then on Friday, Ian and Dan hosted the Friday
Games Review.
Watch as Dan bravely continues the broadcast
despite being under constant mind control
attack from one of the void's nameless terrors.
And on the App Clinic, Ian and I found an
innovative solution to planning our holidays
on company time by reviewing travel planning
and booking apps.
As always you can find all of last week's
shows and the schedule for this week at Google
Developers Live.
That's developers.google.com/live/android.
Coming up this week, catch our Wednesday Office
Hours.
Live from London, Mountain View, and Sydney.
Then on Thursday, Roman and Nick take a shot
at travel planning apps, World Scope, webcams,
and Kayak.
On Thursday's Developers Strike Back, we'll
invite them and the other travel booking apps
developers to provide feedback on our feedback
from the safe distance of a Hangout.
On this Friday's App Clinic we're taking a
look at video player apps at our regular new
time of 10:30 AM Pacific.
Then later that afternoon, Dan will continue
his battle to the death with the void creature
of your choice.
Use the Moderator page link here to nominate
Dan's terrifying opponent and the games you'd
like his co-host to review.
In other Android development news, after a
spirited debate over which '80's power ballad
best describes our team's feelings for the
Android Developer community, our final options
settled on either the Developer Relations
director's Billy Rutledge's suggestion of
classic Whitney Houston ballad, "I Will Always
Love You" and Director of Product Management
Hugo Barra's choice of LMFAO's "Sexy And I
Know It."
Before recording of either could begin, Executive
Chairman Eric Schmidt declared our devotion
to developers Gangnam style while visiting
the Google office in Korea.
Last week also saw the release of Android
miniature collection series three from Dead
Zebra.
Series three features 14 awesome blindbox
designs from a variety of artists.
We also saw the launch of Google Play services.
A new platform that offers Android app integration
with other Google products such as Google+.
Check out the Android Developers blog to see
how Google Play Services makes OAuth2 authorization
available to Android apps with good user experience
and security.
A recent internal debate on improving the
developer experiences concluded that we should
give those developers some badges.
Developers love badges.
I'm happy to announce that these new badges
are now available under the Distribute tab
on the Android developer's site.
Developers looking to improve the display
performance of their apps can now take advantage
of the new Systrace Guide that explains how
to use Systrace tool to collect and review
code execution data from your app in the Android
system, to improve the performance of your
app.
In new and updated apps this week, The New
York Times and Workout Trainer by Skimble
both released updates.
Starting this week I'll be interviewing a
different member of the Android Developer
Relations team in This Week in Android Development.
Here's Ian Ni-Lewis answering the question
"Where do you see yourself in five years?"
>>Ian: Hello everyone, my name is Reto Meier
and welcome to This Week in Android Development.
>>Reto: That was Ian Ni-Lewis offering some
insight into his fondest hopes and dreams.
That's all for This Week in Android Development.
We look forward to you joining us for our
many live shows this week.
And remember, you don't know you're beautiful.
That's what makes you beautiful.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.